start with breaking news in the last few
minutes it's been confirmed that the
former Japanese prime minister Shinzo
Abe has died after he was shot while
delivering a speech in western Japan Mr
ambe served two terms as prime minister
becoming Japan's longest serving Premier
before he stepped down in 2020 following
health problems well joining me now is
our correspondent Nicole Johnston Nicole
this is really going to rock Japan for
any number of reasons I mean he was a
huge figure in post-war Japanese
politics
it's shocking news to come out of Japan
and it will rock not only Japan but the
rest of the world you don't expect to
hear of an attack like this in a country
normally regarded as one of the safest
ones in the world are the video footage
of the attack is dramatic some of it was
captured you can see that he was struck
it appears to have been twice in the
back of the assailant was then wrestled
to the ground you know a large crowd
gathered and eventually Shinzo Abe was
airlifted to hospital now officials have
been saying for the last few hours that
his heart had stopped beating so we were
really just waiting for confirmation of
the news that Shinzo Abe has died
already we have had International
reaction from world leaders before the
news in fact that he had officially been
declared dead we had heard from the U.S
Secretary of State Anthony blinken and
the U.S ambassador to Japan both of them
saying that he had been an outstanding
leader and an unwavering Ally of the
United States Boris Johnson said that he
was utterly appalled by this attack and
of course we'll be raising all sorts of
questions in Japan about how such an
attack could have taken place in such
close range to the former prime minister